ah the sea pig so graceful in its domain
the vast oceans of Earth wait scratch
that this is the sea pig
see the resemblance okay fine whatever
me neither the sea pig is a type of sea
cucumber but this variety lives way
deeper than its comrades down past 3,000
feet
check out those cute little limbs the
called tube feet the seat that keeps
those inflated by pumping water into
them like those long balloons that
clown's use and those wavy and kind of
like things on the top of it they also
happen to you tube feet which the
creature uses to sniff out food and the
sea pig will eat just about anything a
lot like a real pig I guess except a
real pig doesn't have tentacles it uses
to shove bits of decaying matter into
its mouth at least not any pig I've ever
met
so this scavenger serves an important
function as a sort of living vacuum
cleaner on the sea floor and sadly the
sea pig can't defend itself like other
sea cucumbers which can fire toxic tubes
like you see here as well as their
intestines out of their anus I wish I
could say I'm creative enough to make
that up instead the sea pig is highly
toxic
so predator steer clear so truck on
little buddy and be thankful your guts
will never fall out of your bum I know I
am for you I mean not for me
what